không thể tin nổi luôn ấy
bài hát chủ đề World Cup 2.026 mang tên
lighter thực sự khiến fan toàn cầu lắc đầu ngang ngán
bị nhận xét giờ tệ
netizen dần dần đề xuất một Xu hướng âm nhạc mới của
AI đang khuấy đảo mạng xã hội
Argentina Argentina la escaloneta ya llegó
sức nóng của World Cup 2.026 không chỉ nằm trên sân cỏ
mà còn LAN sang cả âm nhạc
thế nhưng ngay khi FIFA công bố bài hát chủ đề lighter
cộng đồng mạng lập tức chia thành nhiều luồng ý kiến
mà đa số là 7 vọng
nhiều khán giả Cho rằng giai điệu khá an toàn
mang vai kiểu pop rock cũ kỹ
nghe giống nhạc quảng cáo hoặc intro giải đấu
đôi vật hơn
là một CA khúc dành Cho giải đấu lớn nhất hành tinh
dù đứng sau là ekip từng thắng Grammy
bài hát vẫn bị đem lên bàn cân với loạt huyền
thoại như Waka Waka
hay wia
the Champions và rõ ràng chưa đủ sức tạo cảm xúc tương tự
không ít người còn thẳng thắn nhận xét
nghe xong mà không thấy vibe World Cup đâu cả
trong khi đó trên mạng xã hội
fan bóng đá lại tự cứu bằng cách tạo trend mới
dùng AI để làm nhạc riêng Cho từng đội tuyển
thậm chí rap luôn tên cầu thủ Theo beat cực cháy
siêu cuồng nhiệt
bất ngờ là những bản nhạc này
lại viral mạnh vì đúng chất bóng đá sôi động
cuồng nhiệt và có cá tính riêng